[Música]
lá espero que estejam confortáveis eu
não estou para nos próximos dois minutos
ao menos falar sobre o que sabemos e não
sabemos sobre a sustentabilidade das
cidades e por que isso é importante
eu já há algum tempo têm vindo a estudar
e tentar compreender as trajetórias
insustentáveis desenvolvimento das
sociedades atuais ea minha formação base
a economia anda de uma o pt não perceber
a importância de diminuirmos e avaliamos
realizado pela coréia é através de
indicadores mas muitas vezes associado
indicadores apenas números e aquilo que
a minha formação e combina um deu foi a
forma entusiasta de olhar para os
números muito para além da visão
objetiva e particular da realidade que
nos pretendem dar só mais tarde percebi
que os indicadores podem nos dar uma
visão muito mais extraordinária do que
uma visão monocórdicas dos números nos
permitem nos despertar consciências dos
indicadores permitem de tornar palpável
e visível é que o que é abstrato é
difícil compreender como a
sustentabilidade e nada mais abstrato
que o ar
conseguimos nós pensar que o avião tinha
peso até o século 17 um ato simbolizava
nada é teve ali larter científicamente
provado o contrário
não sabíamos que o artigo em peso hoje
sabemos que o ar tem peso e hoje vemos
que o ato é uma competição muito
diferente nas cidades e fora dela
hoje vemos em tempo real utilizando os
contra as concentrações de poluentes
os meninos e avaliamos o quanto ar
provoca doenças respiratórias
o quanto à mata os indicadores têm esta
capacidade nos fazer compreender um todo
nos fazer interligar o conhecimento mas
mais do que isso nos fazer é usar a
nossa própria desafiar a nossa própria
percepção do mundo e da realidade e
confessa que foi exatamente isso que
aconteceu com um só indicador e há cerca
de nove anos atrás eu trabalho com
indicadores há mais de 18 anos e tenta
usar os indicadores para usar
portão - para futuros mais sustentáveis
mas consegui ser surpreendida com um
apenas há cerca de nove anos que não
mudo minha pretensão do mundo
eu trago aqui esse indicador expirar
neste gráfico muito simples é publicado
em 2009 pela equipe de cientistas
liderada por rolando rockstrom ea
traffic um simples mostrou ontem segundo
planeta terra
os últimos 100 mil anos do planeta terra
ea oscilação incrível da temperatura
média do planeta terra ao longo destes
cem mil anos espantem se comemos pantai
como foi possível mussum e nos últimos
oito a dez mil anos o planeta a
temperatura do planeta terra estabilizou
estabilizou é níveis continuamente
simpáticos para nós seres humanos
tivesse pensado nos mínimos já que os
picos queremos alguém fura mês nós
teremos aqui pra falar sobre tráfico e
foi esta estabilização nos permitiu
descobrir a agricultura nos permitiu
desenvolver em quantas civilizações até
ao dia de hoje
e este é o único trio na vida da terra
que nos garantiu este desenvolvimento e
este triunfo da vida da terra os
cientistas chamaram de alcino
o drama e olhar para esta imagem pensar
que ela passava
ela só não representam presentes nós já
não estamos sobre uso assim nós não
estamos na era de lógica do aceno de 950
anos pra cá o homem iniciou uma cruzada
que nos fez que nos restar testeiras de
lógica e entrar numa outra era do
antropoceno esta era uma área cheia de
certeza dúvidas de muitas perguntas
sobre o futuro da humanidade no planeta
terra não o futuro do planeta terra o
futuro da humanidade no planeta
então o que temos feito em 1950 anos pra
cá ou mais especificamente a 60 anos pra
cá onde explorar mais o nosso impacto
sobre o planeta terra de uma forma
traumática
seguramente grande parte esta opção deve
se ao crescimento da população mundial
nós triplicamos a população mundial
em pouco mais de 60 anos e concentrados
sobretudo esta população ensinados
hoje vimos que a população urbana em
termos mundiais é mais limitado que a
população total estima se que até 2050
dois terços da população mundial fifa
em finados as cidades são hoje o centro
dos problemas mas sobretudo centro das
soluções para o nosso futuro e nas
cidades que nós criamos a grande parte
da riqueza do mundo nas cidades que nós
criamos mais de 70% da riqueza mundial
mas também nesse natal nós temos as
maiores desigualdades sociais
é nas cidades que nós consumimos grande
parte da energia que é produzida a nível
mundial 60% em energia é consumida na
china dados e mais de 70% das emissões
de gases com efeito estufa é produzida
por força das atividades que ocorrem nas
cidades e as emissões de gases com
efeito estufa são as grandes
responsáveis principais responsáveis
pelas mudanças climáticas e sobretudo
por esta nova era do antropoceno em que
estamos agora na cidade por tudo aquilo
que consumimos geramos mais 30% dos
resíduos produzidos em todo mundo e por
isso mesmo nós sentimos que temos a
seguir ainda não dá sinais de um futuro
grande parte do futuro do planeta terra
e me pergunta para você o que vemos nós
sobre as cidades portuguesas
conseguimos nós conhecer mesmo as nossas
finados encontrar indicadores que nos
permitam conhecer o passado o presente e
sobretudo o futuro das nossas cidades
se você perguntar quando conseguiam
encontrar essa informação quando
tentaram encontrar indicadores que nos
permitisse conhecer melhor as nossas
cidades
provavelmente diriam que como seria o
nosso instituto nacional de estatísticas
é um é nada oficial das estatísticas
portuguesas mas provavelmente teriam
alguma dificuldade em conseguir
encontrar a entrada ou eventualmente a
saída das estatísticas da china em
portugal
leão também consultar plataformas como
por data muito mais interativas fáceis
visualizar de comparar a informação de
discutirmos a informação estatística e
onde até as crianças têm direito
primeiro teste cada e usava para mudar
os seus conhecimentos para mudar as suas
acções na minha perspectiva estatísticas
oficiais mas continuamos a ter uma visão
apresentar a diversidade monocórdica com
muito mais
é muito muito completo e com muito mais
para saber sobre elas
e portanto por que não socorrer as
universidades quanto se produz grande
parte do conhecimento científico um
grande parte da informação está a ser
trabalhada no contexto das universidades
mas provavelmente teremos que abrir
muitas gazetas teremos muitas delas
somente este pó algumas com indicadores
interessantes sobre as cidades mas
teremos muita dificuldade é interligar
toda a informação e sobretudo muita
dificuldade é que esta informação xvii e
nós cidadãos e é nosso senado
o próximo passo realmente seria
consultar por que não o efeito os nossos
municípios são as entidades que melhor
conhecem o território de mais informação
tem mais informação geral sobre as
cidades
acham que conseguiriam encontrar
informação nos sites dos nossos
municípios
a minha percepção é que não não sou ela
tá fechado acerto santos é sexados como
ela está dispersa como ela não está
sistematizado ela não está visível para
nós cidadãos e nós cidadãos não seremos
também nós responsáveis por grande parte
do crescimento das cidades e as nossas
projeções das nossas as nossas
diligências urbanas não fizemos nós
melhor que ninguém
as cidades e jmpla dizia que nós somos
especialistas do carvão vivemos é tão
difícil fazer um conhecimento coletivo
tantas perseguições individuais é tão
difícil dar um sentido coletivo quando
nem sequer conhecemos nossos inglesa mas
para isso temos uma função smart cities
a era dos grandes estádios é das
bicicletas e das novas tecnologias que
nos prometeram libertar divulga os dados
a uma velocidade impressionante mas
muitas vezes somos muito mais dominados
por algoritmos do que temos a capacidade
de compreender o que salvou e nos dão o
que essa informação nos dá e me
perguntei à minha dúvida permanece
conhecemos mesmo as nossas finados são
os mesmo é capaz de refletir sobre ela
vamos dar um exemplo simples ficariam
curiosos por saber que escolas também
ficam estressados nas cidades como nós
os homens produzem 10 vezes mais
proteína e são muito mais ativos na
promoção das energias nas cidades do que
fora delas seriam surpreendidos nos
disser
que quebram nós em termos de circulação
mundial com sumiço mesmo que nós cada um
de nós portugueses precisaríamos de 2.3
planetas terra para manter o nosso
estilo divina e grande parte da nossa
pegada ecológica se dá por aquilo que
conseguimos nas cidades
isso tá pelo consumo de alimentos
poderemos nós pensar que a alimentação
das finais é um dos grandes desafios
ambientais e de saúde que temos pela
frente
a minha perspectiva é que não
conseguimos transformar o que não
conhecemos e temos um grande também pela
frente podemos fazer muito diferente
podemos fazer muito diferente pelas
estatísticas oficiais
não podemos perder visa democratizar o
papel das universidades na transmissão
do conhecimento para minar o papel dos
municípios e todos nós em conjunto para
fazer com que os indicadores movem as
nossas consciências
nós temos muitos exemplos de como isso é
possível em muitas cidades que já fazem
diferentes
temos exemplos como as cidades
concidades de poluição na europa há mais
de 20 anos que colhem trabalham
indicadores contaminados e por isso
tornou-se a capital verde da europa em
temos cidades no estado do que levar
como é o do movimento sindical e os
comunitários surgiu na década de 90 em
cidades como vancouver o enipec
mobilizam a sociedade constroem visões
de terminar com as cidades com base em
indicadores e temos também exemplos
cidades da austrália como melbourne ou
nos estados unidos encontra-se com a
política nacional cidades que postos nos
indicadores da forma como conseguimos
utilizá-los para mudar e transformar as
nossas cidades é minha mensagem final é
sobretudo para que usemos e olhemos para
os indicadores de uma forma muito mais
apelativa vamos usar os indicadores para
despertar as nossas consciências para
compreender que os desafios que temos
pela frente são muito grandes para
debater e comunicar essa informação de
uma forma construtiva e para percebermos
que a realidade se trata do nosso futuro
é determinado também para o futuro do
planeta
vamos usar os indicadores para nos
mobilizarmos para melhorar os nossos
comportamentos isso
tudo para que através da construção de
cidades sustentáveis consigamos
prosseguir a viagem no tempo o planeta
terra
obrigado
[Aplausos]